vamos a hablar un poco acerca de las
definiciones de ácido y de base según
brondsted y laurie y también de la
definición del look de lewis de ácido y
base ok vamos a empezar con la
definición de brondsted laurie entonces
un ácido de brondsted lowry es un
donador de protones muy bien ácido es
donador de protones y una base de bronce
de laurie es un receptor de protones
entonces base es un receptor de protones
y sólo para revis
o más o menos reparas repasar
rápidamente que es lo que esta
definición entiende por protón pues
tenemos por ejemplo aquí este diagrama y
vamos a dibujar el átomo de hidrógeno o
el isótopo más común del átomo de
hidrógeno él se hizo topo tiene un único
protón verdad y un electrón alrededor
del núcleo que sólo consta de un protón
verdad entonces aquí tenemos
un electrón ok y esto lo podemos
representar simplemente como nuestro
átomo de hidrógeno con un electrón
digamos solitario de este lado ahora
bien si nosotros eliminamos este
electrón lo único que nos va a quedar es
justamente el núcleo que sólo es un
protón y éste lo podemos ver como h más
o así lo podemos representar entonces
cuando decimos que cuando hablamos de un
protón en realidad estamos hablando del
núcleo del hidrógeno ahora vamos a ver
cómo esto se aplica a una reacción ha
sido de entre ácido y base así que vamos
a empezar aquí tenemos una molécula de
agua y cuando tenemos hcl ok
tenemos hcl de este lado de la derecha
ahora bien qué pasa cuando juntamos
estas dos sustancias entonces en este
enlace que tenemos aquí entre el
hidrógeno y el cloro uno de estos
electrones déjenme ponerlo así con verde
uno de estos electrones viene del cloro
mientras que el otro electrón
viene del hidrógeno verdad ahí lo tienen
así que para este tipo de reacciones
este par digamos de de electrones
solitarios que se encuentran en el
oxígeno van a tomar a este hidrógeno lo
van a tomar van a separarlo y lo que va
a ocurrir lo que va a ocurrir es que
este par de electrones se lleva a este
hidrógeno y estos dos electrones que
quedan el tanto el azul como el verde
van a pasar a ser parte del cloro
entonces como es que podríamos ver es
exactamente esta reacción o cómo
quedaría pues esencialmente tendríamos
aquí nuestro oxígeno unido a estos dos
hidrógenos verdad y ahora este hidrógeno
que teníamos en él hcl termina uniéndose
a nuestro oxígeno verdad y estos dos
electrones solitarios que estoy pintando
en rojo van a permanecer aquí ahora bien
qué otra cosa ocurre ocurre que como el
hidrógeno pasó a hacer a unirse al agua
entonces vamos a quedarnos simplemente
con el cloro
con sus electrones solitarios que ya
tenía y estos dos electrones en morado
ahora van a pasar a ser parte de este
cloro muy bien entonces qué es lo que
tenemos fíjense que el cloro en este en
este caso ya vamos a tener 8 electrones
y por lo tanto su carga formal va a ser
de menos 1 verdad mientras que la carga
formal de este digamos
la carga formal de este oxígeno va a ser
de más 1 verdad porque aceptó un protón
que viene el núcleo de un hidrógeno un
protón que tiene una carga positiva
mientras que el cloro aceptó un o más
bien se dio su protón que constaba de
este hidrógeno y quedó con carga
negativa entonces justamente a esta
configuración de h 3 o 3 hidrógenos y un
oxígeno se le conoce como el ion
hidronew verdad
mientras que el cloro queda con una
carga negativa volviéndose un año ahora
vamos a ubicar quiénes son nuestros
ácidos y bases
según brondsted laurie entonces nos
fijamos primero en esta sustancia que es
el agua y notamos que aceptó un un
hidrógeno verdad un protón entonces se
acepta o si recibe un protón quiere
decir que entonces es una base de brawn
step lowry mientras que el el hs l que
de hecho ya le podemos llamar así ácido
clorhídrico se dio o donó su protón que
era este hidrógeno entonces éste sería
un ácido de brondsted lowry muy bien
ahora bien no sólo eso también tenemos
sus conjugados hay a qué me refiero con
sus conjugados en realidad a esta
molécula de agua a esta molécula de agua
le podemos asociar
este h3o que es un ácido conjugado
verdad ha sido conjugado mientras que
ahora a esta base a este ácido al ácido
de brondsted lowry le podemos asociar
este que es un su base con jugada con
jugada y esto simplemente es porque
ahora este h3o tiene un protón o una
carga positiva extra que fácilmente
puede donar lo cual lo haría un ácido
mientras que este cloro es tiene una
carga negativa y por lo tanto podría
recibir ese protón entonces esto nos
está diciendo que de hecho esta reacción
es reversible pero no tanto el
equilibrio tiende más hacia la derecha
y de esta forma pues vamos a tener mucho
más productos del lado de la derecha ok
pero esto es sólo esto sólo fue
fijándonos en estas definiciones verdad
el h3 o puede donar un protón y el cloro
puede recibir ese protón así que el
unión de cloro estaría aceptando este
protón y por lo tanto podríamos
garantizar que esta reacción puede ser
reversible y además sabemos que él
hcl el ácido clorhídrico eso ha sido muy
fuerte así que el equilibrio se queda
más bien del lado de la derecha aunque
ya sí que esta es la idea de brondsted y
laurie ahora vamos a ver otra definición
vamos a ver otra definición y qué son
los ácidos y bases de louis ok que de
hecho esta es una definición un poco más
amplia así que un ácido de louis y una
base de louis en realidad se fijan en
los electrones un ácido de louis es
es un receptor de un par de electrones
ok podemos recibir pares de electrones
así que una mientras que la base de
lewis es un donador de pares de
electrones entonces una forma de
acordarse por ejemplo es si tenemos una
base en realidad si lo reflejamos se
vuelve una de verdad del donador
entonces la base es un donador base es
un donador de pares de electrones esa es
una forma para acordarse de que es una
base de louis y por lo tanto el ácido
pues sería lo contrario verdad un
receptor ahora bien vamos a ver una
reacción por aquí vamos a tener esta
molécula digamos
este ciclo digamos tenemos un ciclo con
un oxígeno y sus dos pares solitarios de
electrones
en realidad este es un ciclo o más bien
un éter cíclico verdad ahora bien vamos
a juntar lo vamos a hacerlo reaccionar
con un bora no que esencialmente es un
es un átomo de boro unido con varios
hidrógenos ahí tenemos tres y no tenemos
más electrones verdad de hecho este
borde está rodeado por seis electrones y
eso lo vuelve muy reactivo el boro es
tiene una hibridación sp2 lo que
significa que tiene un orbital p vacío
ok y así podemos tratar no se vamos a
representar el orbital p vacío ok de
esta forma y es y es capaz de aceptar un
par de electrones ahora el éter de aquí
este éter de aquí va a donar un par de
electrones vamos a ponerlos con rojo
este para o más bien con morado verdad
este par de electrones va a poder los
donará este orbital vacío ok y de esta
forma se haría un enlace entre el
oxígeno y el boro entonces de esta forma
podemos ver que este éter donó sus
electrones y el éter donó sus electrones
quiere decir que es una base de lewis
mientras que está este este brom
esta molécula de boro con con hidrógenos
en realidad recibió ese par de
electrones entonces es un ácido de louis
verdad el bora no es un ácido de louis
entonces cómo se vería ahora la molécula
que se genera a partir de esta reacción
podríamos ponerlo de esta forma y se
vería más o menos así entonces tenemos
este ciclo donde tenemos nuestro oxígeno
estos 2 electrones permanecen ahí estos
los electrones permanecen aquí y estos
dos electrones morados ahora forman un
enlace con el boro con el boro que
termina unido con sus tres hidrógenos
verdad tenemos eso entonces qué es lo
que ocurre el oxígeno se dio sus
electrones así que va a tener una carga
formal positiva mientras que el boro
recibió electrones así que va a tener
una carga formal negativa ok así que
tuvimos una reacción de ácido base de
lewis de lewis ok así que ahí estuvo la
definición de ácido y base de luz de
lewis y nuevamente este es un poquito
más amplia que la de bronze taylor y por
ejemplo aquí en este caso en este caso
está el oxígeno cediendo sus electrones
verdad en este caso estamos donando
electrones eso lo vuelve una base de
lewis mientras que el cloro en este caso
más bien el ácido clorhídrico en este
caso está recibiendo ese par de
electrones verdad y así es como
terminamos con esta configuración
entonces esto lo vuelve un ácido de
lewis perdón es un ácido de lewis
y en química orgánica en realidad la
definición de ácido de lewis y base de
lewis tienen una importancia muy
particular porque puedes hablar de
puedes hablar del término de ácido de
lewis como un sinónimo de electro filo
que electro filo electro filo que
esencialmente podría pensarse como que
es amante de los electrones y por otro
lado las bases de lewis son núcleo filos
núcleo filos muy bien que sería como
amante de los núcleos o algo así
entonces estos son dos conceptos
extremadamente importantes y que hay que
entender cuando estamos hablando en
química orgánica